[Music]
if we make all that she's very bastard a
moon Oscar Oscars Karina jazzy will save
my skin Easter so I'm a translator so
you said you shut up because I'm wearing
[Laughter]
because of y'all that brings bad luck so
we do the horns to change the face
[Applause]
linnert wants to thank everybody and
lena wants to dedicate the Oscar
she's a very big American because but
you would like to change the name Oscar
to a feminine name
[Applause]
she would like to call it Anna rather
than Oscar we want to educate the Oscar
Anna to her husband Amalia truly Mia
philia to her daughter can maybe lose
the motivation really she made a
beautiful daughter sometimes feel but
she turned out perfect and then also I
want to thank America over the many
United States and I was ready because
that's a serious thing we're just a
little booth in the middle of this is a
continent you realize it's much bigger
there is no proportion you're big we're
small the next time I would come dressed
in purple
she will undress me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Chah morphine telling you she protects
not to see that I'm wearing
so most of all I want to thank the
United States imagination I want to
thank everybody who loved and supported
my film
I feel those films are a little bit like
my children my own children and then I
want to warn you I could speak for 24
hours
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's only because she feels fantastic
and as compassion toward you she's not
gonna do it I'm here with two wonderful
daughters next time I'm coming I'm
coming naked rather than where she
warned me a warning I'll be naked next
time okay and wonders you only multiple
change in the world you need a lot of
patience multiple shooting and passion
and motivation passion and patience and
then I'm saying goodbye
very heavy so you can't hold it it's
very heavy
[Applause]
beautiful very very next time please
not only the Oscar but also a female
Oscar
[Applause]
yeah so women in the room please scream
we want Ana a female Oscar
[Applause]